hey on today's show we talked to a mom
of a nine-year-old who's had a lot of
life challenges
what can she do to make sure he's okay
we also
talk to a young woman who's from a house
of divorced parents
and she's about to get married and she
wants to know what she can do
to divorce proof her future and finally
we talked to a husband
who loves his wife and he loves his job
that has him on the road all the time
what can he do to stay connected while
he's always gone stay tuned
[Music]
hey what's up what's up i'm john and
this is the dr
john dalone show a show for you
about you by you
where we are walking alongside one
another through trying to figure out the
next
crooked wobbly step in this thing called
life
how to be human beings again how to be
in relationships with one another
and we are figuring it out as we go we
talk about everything on this show
anything and everything no matter what's
going on in your heart in your mind or
your family
in your relationships in this new year
right we've all been waiting for months
and months for it to be 20 21 well here
it is right
we're here and i want you to know that
so many people are going through the
same things you're going through you're
not alone you're not by yourself
and i want you to give me a shout right
give me a shout
give me a call at 1-844-693-3291
or you can go to johndalone.com show and
fill out the form see if we can get you
on the show here
and like i said we talk about everything
on the show and this is a special
episode
it's coming out i think it's january 6th
right it's a special episode
because it's my birthday i am officially
28
it's a big day i'm not 20 i just lied to
you
but here's the thing a new a new 2020
resolution we're all going to make
together 2021
we're all going to make together if
facebook has to tell you that it's one
of your friends birthdays
they're not your friend and you don't
care if
if an algorithm has to tell you when
somebody's birthday is let's just all
call it
you don't care when their birthday is i
don't want a bunch of
people um thumbs upping me right or
being like hey way to go happy birthday
happy birthday if like two or three of
my
people in my life whether it's my mom
and my wife my wife remembers most years
my mom occasionally remembers um i've
got one or two buddies that never forget
they're awesome
but other than that let's just call it
and the second thing is let's don't be
passive aggressive about our birthdays
let's walk into where we work and if you
don't want to say anything don't
if you do just say it hey everybody it's
my birthday like today it's my birthday
show
it's my birthday show let's call it out
let's don't do the passive aggressive
like oh
it's it's it's my birthday thing just
passive aggressive birthday people
let's be done with that in 2021 let's
call it
so here we are on the january 6th happy
birthday show
we're going to talk about the 30 day
sugar free challenge we're going to do
that later
and the reason i wait until january 7th
to do that we're going to start that
tomorrow the reason i wait till january
7th is because my birthday is january
6th and i want that birthday cake man
my wife makes the just murder row
birthday cake and it's awesome
all right so let's get into the calls
directly let's go to rachel
in houston texas where i was born and
raised rachel how are we doing
hey dr lily doing good how are you i'm
doing well thanks for taking my call
thank you so so much for calling how is
houston you doing okay
it's actually cold but we're surviving
wow
very cool i don't hear that very often
so how can i help rachel
so um i have a nine-year-old son with an
ex-husband
and he's been through a lot and i just
want to know
if there is a way in addition to maybe
also seeing a counselor that his dad and
i
can just check on his mental well-being
periodically
ourselves that's a great question
there's a lot to that so when you say a
lot what does that mean
okay so i made a list and i'll try to
just run through these really
really quick okay um after he was born
i had really bad postpartum depression
so i left
and he stayed with his dad he lives with
his dad
still um when he was three i remarried
when his dad i'm sorry when he was four
and a half his dad remarried
um and his dad's wife is really strict
um so much so that if i had to leave
him with her he would cry and then
when we'd get to the house he would stop
because they that was not acceptable
and so it was kind of like a red flag
thing seemed better
um when he was six i had his baby
brother and his great-grandpa passed
when he was eight his regular grandpa
passed from suicide he doesn't know that
i don't want to tell him and then now at
nine we just found out we're having
another baby and i feel like that's a
lot of stuff
right so what behaviors is he putting
out into the world that makes you think
he's not doing okay
well that's the thing there's nothing
like he acts like he's totally
normal what does totally normal mean to
you
i mean he's silly and he is
super loving um
he's a little emotional like i feel like
a lot of boys that i meet that are his
age or
about the same um they i don't know kind
of cry a little bit more than
i would think the boys do but i don't
know i'm a girl right um
and yeah just i just to me
he just seems like he's doing really
well and i just want to make sure that
i'm not missing something so
i'm going to answer the question and
then i'm going to ask you a question
behind that question okay
and one question or the first part of
this will be easy the second part of
this won't be okay
is that cool okay the
reality of it is if he's presenting okay
or i'll just say it this way a young
person a nine-year-old is going to be as
stable
generally speaking as the connection
relationships in their life
and so if he is tethered in to
two parents who truly deeply love him
and
you've heard me say this over and over
touch him regularly
on his face and on his hands and play
with him and
act like he is important to them and
doesn't put the weight of the house on
him
right has appropriate boundaries then
he's going to be okay
and he doesn't have abuse and any of his
relational situations his teachers
may not be the best but they're not
abusing him he's right he's not in
places where he is
being trampled over but most of the time
kids are super resilient especially when
they are connected and when they are
loved
okay so that's the reality of it
i would wait to begin projecting
microscopes or magnifying glasses on him
looking for
problems until he presents them and kids
will not be bashful
you'll see it okay
um if he's got or not
if but as you have laid out his life
you've laid it out where he has suffered
one
trauma after another after another after
another
and he's got some what i would would
call
legacy trauma and take me back to the
person in his life who killed himself
was that a grandparent
yes he only knows that he passed he did
we didn't tell him
how okay and what's the story behind
that passing
um what did his dad tell him i don't i
didn't
ask was it his dad's father yes
okay so somewhere along the way this
young boy has
depression being modeled for him in
on both sides okay
and he's gonna that will he'll have a
reckoning with that at some point
whether that's happening
quietly now or in the future it doesn't
sound like it's happening now so it's
not something i would lose
sleep over especially if he is in a
caring connected
place
and here's where the hard conversation's
going to come into play okay
yes he is going to struggle
with the fact that his parents are
divorced and he is going to struggle
with the fact that at some point
mom left being you okay
have you all had that conversation have
y'all ever talked about that
a lot he um he asks
all the time why did you leave and not
come back
yeah what do you tell him
so my answer has changed since um he's
gotten a little bit older i try to be
like as honest as possible with him so
when he was little
i just told him oh mommy was sick
and she needed her mom and then uh
so now he understands excuse me sorry
uh oh you're okay hey you're okay you're
good
um he understands that
um it was postpartum depression although
he doesn't know
what that what that means right and so
what what role did par
postpartum depression play in you
leaving your husband
was it something that you had to just
get out of there were you feeling you're
going to hurt somebody
what what about postpartum made you have
to leave
um i don't it's really hard for me to
answer that question like i became a
totally different person
okay and i was resenting
my husband and i just had had enough
yeah um and so
i mean it so i'd rather you
begin to take ownership of that decision
instead of
putting it on postpartum depression
because here's what it's going to do for
your son
it's going to make him think that at any
moment this looming thing
is going to come upon me and make me do
something that is going to be
irrevocable
oh yeah and he will live his life under
a
cloud and when he finds out granddad
took his life
that's going to be yet another cloud
that he's always going to be
looking over his shoulder to see if it's
coming after him
oh that makes sense and it feels like
you're doing him a favor by letting him
know
mommy did not leave because of you mommy
didn't even leave
because of her own decision mommy had to
because she was sick
and when a kid is a little you did the
right thing you did a noble thing
and letting somebody know that
somebody's sick that's that's actually
accurate language that's good
but over time you're gonna have to and
it's gonna be
hard because he's going to look at you
and think you chose somebody else other
than him
and to a degree you did you did you
moved out and you're going to have to
reckon with you too
which means you're going to have to go
through a grieving process in a
forgiveness process in a grace process
so that you can be whole for your son
you can be whole for these new wonderful
kids that you've got as well
right and they're worth having a full
whole rachel
right so what's happened has happened
are you remarried yes okay
and you got one new one and another one
on the way
correct okay so
at the end of the day the sooner you can
morph that conversation to one of
ownership
the better the more you're the sooner
your son
realizes that there's not this illness
that's going to take over his mind and
his heart and his character and make him
do evil things
the better the more he learns that he's
ultimately in control of his thoughts
and his actions
the better and
let's deal with dad is dad a good guy
oh he's wonderful you're his birth
father
yeah his dad is wonderful do you regret
leaving him
no okay so it was in your heart was the
right thing to do
i mean i never grew up thought like oh
can't wait to get divorced
right of course but
i'm really happy with
my new husband great okay and yeah and
here's the i take that question back i
asked you an unfair question i don't
hear a lot of people
talk about their ex er as they're so
wonderful
okay so that's fair okay um so i asked
you
i asked you an unfair question so i take
that question back
um all that to say you are blessed
in that you do not have to you're not
walking around feeling you have to
defend or protect your son from his dad
you get to co-parent with him okay we
yes and we i feel like we do a really
good job co-parenting
wonderful wonderful so
have you ever um
been open and honest with your husband
about you about why you left
yes okay i told him that before we even
got married because i wanted it all on
the table
okay gotcha good deal so
here's the thing you and your husband
keep a close eye on your little boy
but not too close let him grow up to be
a little boy
let him know that he is loved with
reckless abandon and when he asks
questions commit to never
ever lying to him
when there is tension in your home which
there's gonna be
right you're gonna have a another young
child he's got
he's back and forth between homes let
him know that his feelings are valid
they don't always tell the truth but his
voice is is one that can be heard
right and he doesn't get to make the
final decision on everything because
he's freaking nine
right and that he is
loved and that he is loved
over and over and over again okay and
the first time he has a bad day or a sad
day does not mean that everybody rushes
off to the counselor
that he's got a psychiatric illness that
he's broken that he needs to go get
counseling
he may just need mom or dad to stop what
they're doing
for a minute and take him fishing to
plug in with him and listen to him
to have a letter writing campaign with
him right
building some of these things now so
that when these
traumas catch up with him in a in a
demonstrative way in a way that we can
all see it
that he goes to you first he doesn't
hide
does that make sense yeah it's super
helpful thank you so you're playing a
five-year game and you're playing a
10-year game
you're loving every day but you want to
when he has to have a conversation with
somebody he wants to think of you first
he wants to thank a dad first there's no
competition between the two of you
and he may fall head over heels for his
stepdad
your new husband he may fall head over
heels for
his stepmom your ex-husband's wife
either way
everybody's on the same page that this
boy is going to know that he is
loved connected swallowed up
in people who care about him and he will
never feel like he is being
haunted by some giant cloud that's going
to take his judgment
take his take his character and
ultimately take his family
and ultimately take his life from him
right i do
expect rachel like being totally honest
i do expect him to have something he's
gonna have to work work work through
in the future probably i also believe he
for as messy as this situation is he is
blessed beyond belief to have two
parents who still love him
and still care enough about each other
to not be idiots and not act like
children
and to just be respectful about one
another
and to um lean into that little boy so
thank you for that call i appreciate you
love that little boy
recklessly and i would say take him to
an astros game but i don't even know
what i think about the astros anymore so
all right let's go to alicia
in chicago alicia how are we doing
i'm doing well dr lonnie how are you i'm
doing so good
so good so how can i help today i
just want to get you know kind of your
your advice on
how does one approach marriage after
growing up with divorced parents
that's an interesting question so
where's that question stemming from are
you about to get married
i'm in a serious relationship just about
two and a half years and we're
being my current boyfriend uh in very
serious talks you know within next year
kind of you know uh preparing for for
that next step
but so before that next step i just have
i have a little hesitation
not from not believing in marriage but
definitely waves in the back of my mind
having
um the fourth parent keep going through
that it's just
it's one of those things i feel like
they could do everything right to
prepare
um but you can't predict the future
still
right so let's answer this big question
number one by the way you may have heard
me laugh you said we're in very serious
talks and that's like contract
negotiation language that i read like on
espn.com so
the way you said that was awesome like
like he put an offer on the table
and you're thinking i don't know about
that i'll take this offer so that just
made me laugh so
um this is a serious conversation how
were you hurt by your parents divorce
um mainly uh i was 15
so you know prime age freshman high
school and an only child
oh man it was very close to becoming
and still very close to my parents so
that was having to
you know split time it was just really
really difficult um my parents did
almost everything right after you know
separating in terms of
they never spoke ill of each other in
front of me they put me first 100
they co-parented i mean they really did
an excellent job after that
um but some of you just can't take away
some of that you know pain and hurt that
it came with
and still today um having just to deal
with it small things like
you know two houses for thanksgiving or
christmas
and you know just it still exists today
even though we're
uh you know 10 years in the future and
just a really great place
so why in the world would you even want
to get married
who's this guy you're married what's his
name um
his name is matthew why in the world
would you even be considering matthew
you've seen it go south you see what
happens and you saw it happen with
people who handle it well
really well yeah why in the world would
you marry matthew
uh well i do i still believe in
marriage and you know really having a
partner you know in life and then
why why why do you believe in that why
do you believe in that i think
i didn't know because i saw it for like
a lot of years my parents for the most
part had a very healthy marriage they
were a team
um you know they were young when they
had me they just fought hard and they
worked really hard and
um just put me first and it was so i had
a
really good childhood only a very loving
home
um and things still didn't work out so
there was a
there was a part of me but now meeting
uh so even before me matthew i still
have you know that hope there to get
married
but then after meeting matthew and
seeing um
he's just a great person and just the
best partner
that i mean he's just like the best
teammate
um and just very very good
so i want to change some of your
language okay
you i loved you listening to you talk
about your parents
right they loved each other they fought
for it they went for it
and then you tossed in something that
was a throwaway line
but it is really heavy and it's really
existential and i want you to never
forget what i'm about to tell you
okay okay the phrase
it just didn't work out
is not real when it comes to
relationships
oh 100 somebody whether it was one
or both made a decision to no longer
continue rebuilding to continue
investing and they pulled their chips
off the table and said i'm out
right 100 and so when you get
married we live in a culture
right you know the stats as well as i do
every friend you have probably has
parents who are divorced every friend
i've got not everyone a number of them
have parents who are divorced
and even some of those who are still
married are just roommates right
we see those you and i both experience
that and so
the reason i was asking you why even do
this why go down this road
and you answer a question
right because having a partner is worth
it
and finding somebody and saying i'm all
in and i'm going to continue to be all
in even as the game changes as the
tables change
as the number of chips we both have to
play changes as we continue down this
wild adventure it's all going to
continue to shift and change
and this phrase it just didn't work out
is
a decision it's not a a
it just for some it does and for some it
doesn't right
and so if you decide to get married to
this guy and you're in very serious
negotiations right now right
right you're very serious talks
i want you to both agree right now that
divorce is
never on the table it is not an option
it can't be an option it won't be an
option
and we're never gonna even have it here
to discuss
and talk through and so once an option
is off the table
then it's it's not an outcome then you
have to
do the other side of that equation which
is let's build
a marriage where we always plan things
together
where we always commit to being
radically honest with one another but
not idiotic honest and there's a
difference
where we budget together and we dream
together and we talk about when those
dreams
change and we express fears and we're
vulnerable with one another and we talk
about past hurts with one another
all these things that somehow stop over
the course of a relationship
and commit to that front end and commit
to
never having divorce as an option
and then your relationship is going to
be as build
i mean as strong as you invest in the
architecture and the continued
re-engineering of this thing
and so i'm going to give you the magic
word here
if you don't want to get divorced choose
not to
marry somebody that chooses not to
and can i give you one more
uncomfortable moment
yes all relationship 100
of it is a risk and it's a risk on the
front end
and it's a risk all the way through it
and if you knew the outcome if you knew
how it ends
it wouldn't be a relationship right
it would be a it would be a business
arrangement
and so no going in that there is no
there is no guarantee on the back end
that's what makes it so exciting and so
scary
and so beautiful right it's a choice
and so as you hear me say that it sounds
trite and silly right
yes or no talk to me about it
well no it yeah it doesn't sound silly
just i very much
know a person who um likes control and
would you know like to do like
everything to work out
but because i made every right decision
i possibly could so
um i think since now but up until now
i haven't really looked beyond you know
five years in the future whether it was
high school
and college and you know early in my
career so now
the thought you know looking okay let's
stream
you know 10 20 30 years in the future
it's like whoa whoa that feels like out
of my reach that i have control over
um you know it is just scary and and
that's basically it
and uh and that is that hey that's the
rest of your life that's what's so cool
about this
that never goes away the moment it stops
being scary is the moment that people
start looking over the shoulder
right the moment that people get
comfortable and they lean back and
they're like that's all right
is the moment they stop investing in new
architecture
they stop trying to build a stronger
foundation
they stop trying to do the repair work
on on this relationship
and then the whole thing they find it in
ash
right so it is risky it is exhausting
it is forever and whatever you think
you're planning for 20 years from now i
promise
i promise it will be different i work on
the radio now
i have instagram for god's sake i had
like one
promise on earth is that i would never
have instagram
that was stupid right so whatever my
plan was
i wish i could go back and tell you what
my plans were when me and my wife were
dating
it probably involved i do don't even
want to get into it it's not what my
life is now and my life is
a thousand times better than i could
have pictured it
and for whatever it's worth there have
been multiple
two or three or four times over the 20
plus years
i've been dating and have been married
to my wife
when we reached an apex and said this
could be
this could be it and we chose not to
we chose not to quote unquote
just say ah let's call it it didn't work
out
we didn't take our chips off the table
we may have got up and walked away from
the table for a minute and walked around
and then sat back down and said these
are the cards i've got what cards do you
have let's lay it all out on the table
and let's rebuild again and let's
rebuild again and let's keep rebuilding
again
i love alicia i love that you're asking
these questions i love that you are a
person who loves control
and i want you to know
you are you are putting that on the
table when you go all in on somebody
else
and if you're listening to this and you
don't under you don't hear anything else
i'm high on marriage i still think it's
got
it's it's one of the most important
cultural touchstones of our time
and i don't believe and things just run
their course and i don't believe in
things just
didn't work out i believe that people
change
and i believe people grow and i believe
people change and grow together
and i also believe people at some point
just cash in and say i'm out
i'm done i can't be here with you
because you won't do x i can't be there
with y because she won't do x y and z
and it's a risk it's a risk it's all in
it's a risk
but alicia i said go for it all right
let's go you know what before we take
this last call
i wanna i wanna talk about the
the january 7th the january 7th
month the sugar-free month from january
7th
to february 7th i'm hoping that everyone
listening to this will join me in this
here's the thing we can not deny
i guess science has got a bad rap these
days we can't deny the science
we can't deny the um
reality that we're not sleeping
we are sick we are overweight we are out
of shape we are not
moving we are not um
nutritionally sound neurologically
neurobiologically
at the end of the day guys that starts
with sugar
and we are eating trash
we are over consuming sugar and other
sweeteners
logarithmically way way too much
and so there is all these fake fad diets
here's the thing i was obsessed with fad
diets and you know
what kind of nerd i am i used to keep
spreadsheets and tracked my progress i
need to go back and find them i don't
even know if they exist anymore
but i kept spreadsheets i bought my own
glucose monitor
um i had a scale for all stupid good
that did which it does about no good
um but i had all these different metrics
and i would track fad diets and so
i would come home and every month i got
to where my wife would be going to the
store and she's like hey what are we
this month i'd be like we are raw vegan
right we are gluten free or paleo or
keto whatever it is
and there's all these different diets
here's a couple the
that we pulled off the internet vegan
gluten-free dairy-free paleo-keto
intermittent fasting
that's not really a diet more it's not a
diet bro it's a lifestyle
the carnivore diet atkins whole30
cabbage soup diet grapefruit diet juice
cleanse charcoal detox
awesome baby food diet weight watchers
the 5x5
the fill in the blank right not to
mention all the powders and potions and
pills that help you lose weight fast
lose weight fast for 19.95 plus shipping
handling they don't have shipping and
handling anymore do they
they just have all free shipping that's
a bummer i didn't think about that
but here's the thing some of you are
already a week into the new year
and if you listen to the earlier podcast
you considered yourself a person who's
going to be a steward of their body
right and you maybe did something dumb
like i said i want to lose 50 pounds i'm
going to put a number on it i want to
let's all just agree to do one thing i
want everyone to join me
january 7th to february 7th january 7th
to february 7th
no sugar that's no sugar
no artificial sweeteners that's
basically water and tea and coffee
right toppo chico if you're into the
bubble water
oh my gosh it's so good um
but no cokes no diet cokes
no orange juice right
the fruit juice is loaded with sugar
no gatorades right no sports drinks no
red bulls
there's no sugar candy the work did the
work you know the dish of candy
no gummy candies for guys like me oh my
gosh
my birthday is today so i'm gonna have a
birthday cake tonight and then i'm off
starting tomorrow and i hope you'll join
me then you commit just give yourself 30
days of no sugar
what's going to happen is this you're
going to feel like you got hit by a bus
in about a week you're going to feel
terrible you're going to have headaches
you're not going to sleep it's going to
be uncomfortable
and i'm going to tell you to push
through i'm going to be posting about it
on instagram you can follow me at john
delony
you are going to begin to feel
uncomfortable and then you're going to
realize
oh my gosh i'm an addict i'm an addict
if you're really into this try no
alcohol for 30 days because alcohol
reduces itself to a sugar in your body
too
it has a very similar not including the
alkal
not including the the alcohol part it
has a very similar glycemic response to
just regular sugar
so try no alcohol but for
for all intents and purposes cut the
sugar
30 days you can do it you're gonna feel
terrible and after about a week after
about two weeks
you are gonna feel like somebody pulled
a cataract off your face off your eyes
off your soul
you're going to feel yourself full of
energy you're going to feel yourself
walking around taller you're going to
feel yourself
looking at people in the eye it is magic
and it starts with getting off sugar by
the way you got to eat healthy on the
back end too you can't just cut out
sugar and just do nothing else right
so eat healthy get good good healthy
fats
eat good protein right eggs and good
meats
take care of your body take care of
yourself but let's cut the sugar for 30
days
i want everyone to go for it and let's
see what's on the back end
if you get off sugar for 30 days and you
don't see any radical improvement in
almost every area of your life
holler back girl at me and let me know
and i will read
your i will personally discredit myself
on this show
it'll be awesome all right let's take
one more call let's go to john in
springfield
missouri john what's happening brother
how we doing
hey i'm not so bad how are you good not
so bad
hey real quick do you say missouri or
missouri
no the correct way is missouri i'm here
to settle the argument i heard it both
ways but the right way
missouri you are the greatest person
i've talked to all day
and that makes me happy every once in a
while
somebody totally comes through in the
clutch john and you just did
you don't have to go to church this week
you don't have to be nice to most people
you're good you are squared up thank you
so much for being able to
read right but good for you all right so
how can i help you
you help me how can i help you right so
i do a lot of traveling for work and
my wife and i need some help
strategizing and
getting the tools to be better when
we're apart
my job has been traveling all over the
state out of state
for surprise trips of a day at a time up
to a week of a time i've got conferences
all across the country
and classes that i have to take all over
the place
and whenever we spend time apart
it's it's difficult i mean she's great
and i think she thinks that i'm pretty
great too
and we talk a lot but um sometimes it's
hard for me to focus on my job
sometimes it's you know just lonely
being in a hotel room looking at the
ceiling
um are there ways that we can or are
there things that we can do
to make the most and really you know
try and get through these times i hate
feeling like i'm just
you know having to trudge through is
there a way that we can
make this time better when we're apart
man that's an awesome question i
appreciate that
um let's think through that together
first what kind of work do you do
i'm in cyber security cyber security and
so
even with the shutdown this year they've
had you traveling all over and still
attending things and learning things and
being in people's
drawers and whatnots less than usual
um i work a lot with the cameras and
door won't
close or door won't open part of it so
uh
you know if the door won't close i gotta
go out there and close the door
i gotcha okay and tell me about this
lovely wife of yours does she
vocalize that she doesn't like your job
do you just sense it on her
um no it's
she doesn't like my job and it's much
more of a
of a distance thing um
what is it about this job that makes you
want to keep this gig
i i love it okay like from the bot like
it's what i'm supposed to be doing
okay ever since i was a little kid i
would you know be eating waffles in the
morning and
getting on the computer and learning
like this is it's a dream job
really what's the dream part about it
the cyber security part of it the
internet's part of it solving problems
part of it what's the dream job part of
it
it's it's the solving problems and you
know sometimes it's
it's more difficult for me to say that
in others when you're just a little bit
you know deep into the problems but man
i just love it it's
it's a calling i i'd like to help
people and i like to you know
get online and you know fix problems and
work through stuff and be able to
provide solutions to people
you know immediately and seeing that
immediate result it just
it feels really really good and um i'd
like to think that i'm okay at it i get
paid to do it yeah
so i'm gonna tell you something hard
that i just heard okay
when you were first called and you were
talking about your marriage
and your wife and she's you love her and
she's good
you said all the right things you said
all the right things that were good and
noble
and then when you talked about your job
you came alive
is that indicative of your relationship
i don't think so okay i'll be honest
with you
it's it's easy for me to get chatty
about my job
okay i'm pretty close to the chest about
my relationship
it's it's actually pretty difficult for
me to to talk to people about it
and you know that's that's part of the
reason why it's it's been tough for
for the both of us because i you know
i'm going on these trips and i feel like
i'm doing the same thing
you know and it's hard for me to reach
out to somebody and ask them you know
i've got this issue yeah and how am i
supposed to address it i'm used to just
fixing things
as i go and knowing the solution just
making it happen right
so at the end of the day you talk about
your job as your calling
something you've wanted since you were a
little kid and i want you to put
that same sort of
existential weight on your marriage and
specifically that woman that you
promised yourself to for the rest of
your life
and so i want you to have very clear in
your heart and mind that if
it ever comes to a point that you've got
to choose between the two that's going
to be
a difficult but clear-cut decision
and that will fall to your wife and i
want you to start
there because anything else is going to
be strategy
and marriage can't survive on strategy
strategy's a part of it right so you're
calling and saying what can i do
in a hotel well man they've got face
time there's got all kinds of
of mutual games they've got all kinds of
stuff you can do
but at the end of the day your wife has
to feel
as valuable as this job is and she
probably
maybe she does she has to feel as though
not only have you is is your job a
calling something you've thought about
since you were a kid
but that she is your purpose
she is why you get up and will
get up in the middle of the night and
catch a 4am flight to go
fix a door right
yeah she is
and i can't i can't shake the fact john
that it
sounds like there's a a values
misalignment here okay
she has permission to struggle with you
being gone the same as you have
permission to struggle being gone
what it sounds like you all need to do
is get in a room together maybe i've
already done this
but get in a room together and
talk openly about what this job with the
travel is costing you
and maybe nothing maybe it's just
some frustration it's annoying right
it's just
man i'm gone a lot and i'm struggling
with it
or maybe it's way deeper than you think
maybe if you sit down with her and y'all
start going through she's going to open
up to you in a way that's going to be
really hard
or maybe this shutdown you've traveled
less and you've realized
this is my calling i love this job i
love problem solving i love doing on the
interwebs
but man i love being around my wife i
haven't been around her this much ever
and i love it and the thought of getting
back on the road is starting to
make me real uncomfortable and what i'll
tell you john is millions of people are
reconsidering
their profession and their quote unquote
calling i work with some of the best
it folks on planet earth and they go
home every day at five o'clock
and they make great money and they work
their butts off and we have
are recruiting them all of the time and
so i'm telling you to tell you there
are security jobs there are i.t jobs
there are internet
jobs that don't always require hopping
on a plane and heading off and solving
that sort of problem there may be that
you are going to find a job that's
different than the one you have
but in a similar field that still feels
like the calling is still meeting that
need with you
in terms of things you can do man it's
all about intentionality
it's knowing what is your wife missing
when you're gone besides your physical
presence
it could be a you're always writing
letters to one another that you can
hold and tangibly touch that you have
some rules and regulations and i say
rules loosely
um you've you're invited to one another
that you're always going to step out of
whatever meeting you are at these
intervals throughout a day
and talk to each other on facetime
you're going to make sure you facetime
each other watch a movie together at
night
all of this is a distant second and
third and fourth
actually being in the same room together
but it's again it's just strategies
um i actually like the idea of watching
a movie together with the other person
on facetime even though it's kind of
weird
um but who who knows man but it starts
with you guys
sitting down and figuring it out again i
don't want to keep
circling back and saying the same thing
over and over john but there's something
else here that we could talk about for
hours and hours
that sounds like there's a disconnect
between you and your wife
and this spiritual calling you have with
your work
so tonight i want you to turn all the
electronics off in the house
i want you to sit down with your wife
and i want you to have a hard
conversation with her
maybe not a hard one but a direct one an
open one on everything on the table
conversation
about how much you love her about how
much you love spending time with her
and i want you to ask her to be
vulnerable with you about
how she feels about your traveling how
she feels about you being gone how she
feels
about you being home more this season
and then come up with
a plan together co-create a plan
together of what travel's gonna look
like
what distance is gonna look like and is
this
actually the right job for you long term
because man you may have been called to
this job
but you promised that young woman you
for the rest of your life
right thank you so much for that call
john from springfield missouri he said
it right and i love it
as we wrap up man it's one of my
favorite songs of all time
i still randomly find myself singing
this when i'm walking down the street
when i'm just taking out the trash this
song just pops in my head when i was a
kid i used to listen to it on a cassette
player
you had to hit record and play at the
same time
when it came on the radio kids and he
had to record it on a blank cassette
tape
said the 900 year old man and i used to
record this song off the radio
and play it over and over and over again
it's off the 1989
pump album by one of the legendary bands
aerosmith
steven tyler and company sing this
classic song
what it takes and it goes like this
there goes my old girlfriend there's
another diamond ring and
all those late night promises i guess
they don't mean a thing so baby what's
the story did you find another man
is it as easy asleep in the bed that we
made when you don't look
back i guess the feeling starts to fade
away i used to feel your fire but now
it's cold inside
and you're back on the street like you
didn't miss a beat yeah
so tell me what it takes to let you go
tell me how the pain is supposed to go
tell me how it is that you can sleep in
the night without thinking you lost
everything that was good in your life to
the toss of the dice
tell me what it takes to let you go
tell me what it takes to let you go
ladies and gentlemen this has been
the dr john dolone show
[Music]